ever wondered how millions of tons of
vegetables are harvested each year it's
a question that might seem simple but
the answer is a symphony of precision
timing and hard work today we embark on
a journey of Discovery a quest to
understand the intricate dance of
Agriculture that puts food on our tables
every day farming the very backbone of
civilization is a Marvel that often goes
unnoticed it's an art that's been
refined over thousands of years a
testament to Human genuity and
perseverance from the first seeds sewn
by hand to the modern-day marvels of
Machinery the story of farming is one of
evolution and
adaptation as we begin our journey we'll
be exploring the cultivation and
harvesting of four vegetables that are
Staples on dinner plates around the
world fennel red cabbage green onion and
broccoli each of these vegetables has a
unique story to tell a tale of growth
and harvest that reflects the dedication
and skill of the farmers and tend to
them fennel a crisp vegetable with a
sweet anike flavor is more than just a
tasty addition to your salads it's a
testament to the delicate balance of
Nature and the farmer's skill a balance
that ensures every bulb is harvested at
the peak of its freshness and
flavor red cabbage vibrant and full of
nutrients Tells A Tale of careful
cultivation and precise harvesting it's
a story of color and crunch a narrative
that unfolds in the vast Fields where
these cabbages grow green onion a
versatile and flavorful vegetable speaks
volumes about the Precision and timing
required in farming every onion
harvested is a testament to the farmer's
Keen Eye and Steady Hand broccoli with
its distinctive green fluet is a
testament to the farmers's ability to
nurture and care for their crops coaxing
out the very best these plants have to
offer this journey is about more than
just understanding how these vegetables
are harvested it's about about
appreciating the labor the love and the
Legacy that goes into every bite we take
so without further Ado let's dive into
these vast fields and discover the
harvesting process starting with fennel
fennel a flavorful herb with a rich
history is the first stop on our journey
this unique plant with its feathery
leaves and robust bulb is a staple in
many kitchens around the globe but how
does it get there from the fields of the
farm let's start at the very beginning
fennel seeds are sewn directly into the
soil in early spring or fall depending
on the Region's climate the seeds are
tiny but they pack a punch each one
holding the potential for a new fennel
plant once they're in the ground it's a
waiting game as nature takes its course
as the seeds germinate and Sprout they
begin their transformation into mature
fennel plants over the course of several
weeks the small seedlings grow and
develop into plants that stand tall with
Lush feathery fronds and thick bulbous
bases these bulbs are the part of the
plant we're most familiar with in our
kitchens adding a crisp sweet Anis
flavor to our dishes so how does this
mature fennel make its way from the
field to our plates well that's where
the magic of modern farming comes in the
process of harvesting fennel is a
delicate balance of timing and technique
the plants must be harvested at just the
right moment when the bulbs are at their
Peak size and flavor
this usually happens about 3 months
after
planting once the fennel is ready
farmers use specialized Machinery to
harvest the plants these machines are
designed to carefully uproot the fennel
ensuring the bulbs remain intact and
undamaged the harvested fennel is then
quickly transported to a processing
facility where it's cleaned sorted and
packaged ready to be shipped to markets
and grocery stores remember the Journey
of fennel doesn't end at the super
Market it continues in your kitchen
where it brings flavor and nutrition to
your meals from the field to your
kitchen that's the Journey of fennel
next we head to the vibrant fields of
red cabbage known for its vibrant color
and health benefits red cabbage is a
staple in many
kitchens the Journey of the red cabbage
from seed to your salad bowl is an
interesting one it all begins with the
careful planting of seeds in the fertile
soil these seeds tiny caps of potential
are nurtured by the farmers ensuring
they receive the right amount of
sunlight and water over time they sprout
into young cabbage plants their leaves
unfolding like a story waiting to be
told as the weeks pass these young
plants grow and mature their leaves
turning from a pale green to the deep
rich red we all recognize the
transformation is not just a visual One
the red cabbage is busy synthesizing
nutrients making it a Powerhouse of
vitamins and antiox oxidants now comes
the exciting part the Harvest it's not
just about plucking the matured cabbage
from the ground modern farming
techniques have turned this into an
efficient mechanized process specialized
machines Guided by skilled operators
glide through the fields their sharp
blades cut through the thick cabbage
stems leaving the heads of cabbage
untouched these heads are then collected
by the machine sorted based on size and
quality and sent on their way to be
cleaned and packaged
the harvesting process is a delicate
balance of speed and Care the machines
have to move quickly to cover the vast
Fields but also gently to avoid damaging
the cabbages it's a dance of precision
and efficiency choreographed by the
farmers and their machines what's
remarkable is the sheer scale of this
operation thousands of cabbages are
harvested in a single day each one
destined for a kitchen somewhere ready
to be transformed into a delicious dish
a fascinating process isn't it now let's
move on to the pungent world of green
onions green onions small But Mighty add
a punch to our dishes these slender
greens though diminutive in size are
packed with flavor and nutrients their
cultivation process is just as
fascinating as their culinary uses the
Journey of a green onion begins with
planting the seeds are sewn directly
into the soil usually in the cool early
spring months these tiny seeds once
nestled into the Earth begin their
transformation under the watchful eye of
the sun and the nurturing touch of the
rain as days pass the green onion starts
to sprout pushing through the soil to
reveal tiny green chots these chots grow
into slender stalks their Roots firmly
anchored in the nourishing soil the
green onions continue to grow their
stocks lengthening their bulbs swelling
until they reach the right size for
harvesting now let's talk about the
harvesting process it's a sight to
behold hold when fields of green onions
are ready for Harvest their vibrant
green stalks sway gently in the breeze
their white bulbs peeking out from the
earth the harvesting process is done
using specialized Machinery large metal
Contraptions move slowly across the
fields their blades slicing through the
soil to lift the green onions these
machines are designed to be gentle
ensuring that the green onions are
harvested without damage once harvested
the green onions are care Yul sorted the
larger more mature onions are separated
from the smaller ones this sorting
process ensures that only the best green
onions make it to our kitchens the
harvested green onions are then packed
into crates ready to be transported to
markets and stores each green onion from
its slender green stock to its white
bulb is the result of careful
cultivation and meticulous harvesting
and that's how the humble green onion
makes its Journey our final stop is the
broccoli Fields scen script broccoli the
green Powerhouse is our final vegetable
for today let's delve into the world of
broccoli a vegetable that's just as
fascinating to grow as it is nutritious
to eat the cultivation process of
broccoli is a taale of patience and
precision with each stage of growth
demanding careful attention it all
begins with the seed sewn in a nurturing
bed of soil as the seedlings emerge they
are coddled and protected shielded from
harsh weather and pests slowly but
surely these tiny seedlings grow into
sturdy plants their strong stems
supporting clusters of green buds the
broccoli we're familiar with but the
journey doesn't end here oh no the real
magic happens when these Emerald Gems
are ready for Harvest this is when the
farmer's hard work truly pays off the
broccoli plants now mature and robust
are primed to offer up their nutritious
Bounty the harvesting process is an
orchestration of machinery and human
skill large automated Harvesters roam
the fields their sharp blades slicing
through the thick stems with Precision
it's a mesmerizing sight watching these
mechanical Giants perform their task
with such finesse but it's not all
machine work the human element is
crucial in ensuring the quality of the
Harvest each head of broccoli is
inspected for size color and firmness
this is where the farmer's Keen Eye and
seasoned judgment come into play only
the best make the cut ensuring that
every bite you enjoy is of the highest
quality once harvested the broccoli is
swiftly transported to a cooling
facility here it's quickly chilled to
preserve its freshness before being
packed and shipped off to markets and
supermarkets across the globe the
process of broccoli farming and
harvesting is a testament to the harmony
between man and machine a symphony of
hard work precision and Technology it's
a taale of dedication from the seed to
the Supermarket aisle and there you have
it from the field to your plate the
Journey of these four vegetables
remember every bite you take has a story
to
tell